[Music]
New Year's was was really the actual New
Year's Eve was fun and then I started
off in New Year's so sick so insanely
sick and I'm at this age now where I've
actually read a lot of articles about
health with health tips and stuff which
I realize that's a that's a big sign
that you're getting older is that you
actually pause to read articles about
you know the eight superfoods that you
should be winning your twenties you like
I'll never die I don't care and then
when you get to be 44 you're like what
can blueberries do could they baby
things are falling out of me maybe I
should help me blueberries so um they so
one of the things that one of these
articles said was when you get sick take
no medicine let all the symptoms you get
when you run iNOS and diarrhea and
vomiting and aches that's not the that's
not the virus that's your immune system
going to work that's like the battle is
going on and you're just kind of so I
said okay I'm just gonna lie here I'm
going to let the because here's the
thing is when the immune system is doing
its stuff and you take medicine you're
screwing with your own immune system
it's like when you have and this is
going to gross no it's not going to
sound gross this is gross when you have
diarrhea that's like your immune system
is having a victory party because
they're saying we just flushed the virus
out and if you take pepto-bismol
the virus is like guess who just got
locked inside here boys it's almost like
your immune system is John McClane and
you're helping out Ahn's Gruber inside
the Desai scraper sending of weapons
making it if you like
this guy heart eventually you know well
it's either die hard or he is asleep
well my my studio what am i doing
alright so um it's either uh hoping
eventually you get up on the back of it
that would be I know I'm like fidgeting
like am I am i smoking on my shoulder
like the Lemur yeah like have a balloon
of heroin in my ass um let that sit
there
I got a screener of the the new Hobbit
movie so what I was sitting there is a
desolation of smaug the desolation of
smaug so i decided i would watch it and
i would pretend like what was going on
inside of me was this this grand
middle-earth battle so when i would
while you were sick yeah like I was like
okay there's a huge battle going on so I
would get up when I would get up and run
and throw up in my mind it was like
they've just they've just destroyed the
bridge of Bharath or or something I
don't know but it was I was trying to
make it Noble and then I kind of ruined
The Lord of the Rings for myself because
I was thinking what if all the Lord of
the Rings movies are just a huge
metaphor for a guy with a really ugly
stomach flu and every time Gandalf you
know says you shall not pass it's just a
guy just we're just taking this massive
dump I'm just I'm just saying that the
dragon should have been called diarrhea
in that movie
based on what I went through the
desolation of diarrhea I think it's a
good thing that they did not go with
that title